eu sou mestre do kung fu
Jackie Chan
[Música]
do
pijama
Fala chefe
é
limpinho
Não
[Música]
foi isso que eu te ensinei
desculpa chefe sabe que você é meu
malvado favorito né
então eu gosto muito de luta né que eu
perdi aquela famosa que eu fiz a
Ah é mesmo agora o seguinte eu tô tão
inspirado em Minions 2 A Origem de Gru
que eu resolvi aprender kung fu e vou
até fazer uma publicidade para mim nos
dois a origem de grupo a origem do grupo
enfim você sabe por quê que o nome do
filme é esse porque nesse novo filme dos
minions a gente vai ver a origem de
grupo que diz que os meninos Até
aprender o kung-fu disse a entender a
eles se tornaram O Meu Malvado Favorito
tá vendo aí o cara você fica tão
empolgado que você já emitir o cara
nossa muito legal que bacana aprender
uma nova arte né E quando é que vai ser
a gravação deixa eu ver aqui na agendas
e amanhã à tarde eu tenho horário das
duas a 5:00 a gente aprende das duas a
cinco e eu gravar noite não é possível
aprender como foi um dia algum quem você
está falando o Whindersson Nunes eu faço
um monte de coisa eu tenho uma técnica
para fazer várias coisas ao mesmo tempo
quer saber fazer tudo mal feito
e
sim eu aprendo qualquer coisa só olhando
olha não é assim que funciona como foi
coisa séria para alguém aprender como
for são necessárias dez anos de
Treinamento a pessoa precisa aprender
sobre os três pilares gente e Xem
Essência energia espírito agora que não
tem raiz forte não gera frutos box por
exemplo é diferente existe blocos de rua
kung fu não existe o kung-fu de Rua
Conde for de rua box de rua O que tem a
ver uma coisa com a outra se eu tiver
fazendo Kung Fu no lugar e eu chamar bem
para Rua vê se tu é o cabra nele vem não
tá comigo aí não é o kung-fu de rua é
lógico
o
peixe eu acho que tem os malfeitores aí
vai lá ver vai lá ver o que você não
disse que é dez anos para aprender eu
você já tem 10 anos no teu amor tô
começou a começar amanhã primeira mas
vamos lá vai vai na frente você é a dona
da empresa vai na frente eu vou atrás da
reta sempre pode ver alguém por trás
Olha isso aqui carro deve ter uns 500
mil inscritos a gente para cá é
E aí
o
que que Elton concentrada aqui
tá ouvindo ouvindo o quê
Como assim o seu cérebro de bactérias
que você não disse que tava fazer o
vermelho eu achei que tava
duas da tarde e
[Música]
eu
não sei lá
[Música]
E aí
o
[Música]
óleo você relaxa mesmo ela é uma arte
você realmente aprende muito rápido
parabéns viu aí acho que era até para
gravar publicidade já tá gravado
inclusive assim Como assim você não
percebeu que eu tô com microfone eu
também exatamente o que a gente é muito
rápido a gente bota as coisas pra gravar
antes da própria o seu saber ali os
menino tudo à toa uma plateia tá vendo
Avatar gente bom demais eu bati ninguém
viu aqui ó Guilherme olha pode já pode
falar aqui ó as estão as minhas dois
além de Guru a sexta os meninos dois
origem de grupo já está no cinemas
compre logo seu ingresso aqui o pessoal
é rápido nós estamos só pra gente a
gente faz rápido é o boas cenas de ação
[Aplausos]
Oi Adriana banana iguanas tipo lata
[Música]
por favor e
E aí
[Aplausos]
e
[Música]
agora é
o
jogador está animado em
E aí
[Música]
oi
kkk Oi
e eu queria ganhar um
[Música]
E aí